dorothy did not know what to say to this  for all the people seem to think her  witch why aren't you married  um  i was with i was with somebody for a  long time lisa  and she knew very well she was only an  ordinary little girl who'd come by the  chance of a cycling into strange land  you still do  then why did you break up  i don't know  when she had tired watching the dancing  block bach let her into the house ray  gave her a room with a pretty bitterness  i don't think it was my choice  i think um  you love each other  and then  you still love each other  but find it hard to express  that love to each other  and so then  you look at each other  and you do this  and you go ah  yeah i mean i hope you don't have the  experience but you probably will  it's all right  actually  um  sheets were made of blue cloth and  dorothy's  [Music]